good morning Hank it's Tuesday so many
nerdfighters made amazing book towers
that I figured I should give it a try
myself so let's head up to the library
by the way Hank I have a library well I
have this voiceover opportunity I want
to recommend three recent reads first
tondc Coates is amazing book between the
world and me which I cannot stop
thinking about second the bail trap link
in the doobly-doo an article in The New
York Times that explores one of the
reasons people in poverty are
disproportionately imprisoned in the
United States and third another article
in The New York Times about a
fourteen-year-old boy locked in solitary
confinement which I found chilling and
deeply upsetting also since those are
all tough reads I recommend a Jif of a
puppy jumping for the first time link in
the doobly-doo oh well there you have it
Hank couldn't build a house of cards in
2007 and can't build a house of books in
2015 some things never change okay
insert artful transition here Hank I
took the nerdfighter census survey
yesterday great survey as always but I
felt like some of the questions weren't
inclusive of me like the question do you
follow John on Twitter I just didn't
know how to answer that because
technically I don't but I also kind of
feel like I do I mean I see most of
John's tweets also you asked me whether
I watch videos at school which I don't
because that would be creepy but not
whether I watch videos at work which I
do because technically like watching
Akilah Hughes get drunk and review books
is my job well bad and semi-professional
FIFA playing speaking of which Hank
behold the wonder of the John Green
stand at AFC Wimbledon Stadium okay hey
but there was one question I did not
appreciate it all question 25 the one
where you pit my beautiful unwavering
puffs against your fancy new hairstyle
by asking who has better hair Hank or
John I think we use the nerdfighter
census every year to figure out what
topics we should cover on crash course
and what sort of videos we should make
on vlogbrothers and it helps us to
understand the interests and passions of
nerdfighteria and I'm so grateful to
everyone who fills it out but I don't
want to submit my hair to a popular vote
in fact I'm just seeing that question
made me go out and get this haircut and
I'm worried that soon in an attempt to
impress nerdfighteria and when there
Pylea support will have an
ever-escalating arms race like the US
and the Soviets did in the 1980s only
with hair instead of nuclear weapons
until eventually one of us
bankrupt and our Empire collapses is
that what you want Hank and yes I did
just use the word pie leus meaning of or
relating to hair this whole hair thing
is making me so anxious to my
vocabularies coming out
Hank one of the weirdest and most
beautiful things about nerdfighteria is
that in eight years they've never
allowed us to have like a proper sibling
rivalry it's ever been about team Hank
or team John it's always been about team
Hank and John or as I prefer to think of
a team John and Hank but you put that
question in the survey Hank so I guess
you want a contest and you're gonna get
one here's the thing about John's hair
Hank you may not always agree with it
but you have to respect its honesty
John's hair the puff has remained
fundamentally unchanged over the last
eight years it grows and shrinks with my
anxiety levels but at its core the puff
is the puff this is hair without product
or artifice or gimmicks I'm not sure you
can say that about Hanks hair but I'm
not gonna run a negative campaign you're
never gonna hear me say hey what's it
like having a haircut to Tyler Oakley
discarded in 2011 and I would never
point out that Hank has the haircut of a
young Republican and the face of a Dimas
Dashie ode we on Trotsky no you'll never
hear that from me because my hair is
keeping it positive
let me just submit that a vote for
John's hair is a vote for stability and
brotherhood and unity so friends please
fill out the 2015 nerdfighter census and
when you do consider the puff also if
you have a job please fill out the
nerdfighter census because right now I
can't tell if it's selection bias or if
the unemployment rate in nerdfighteria
is actually 85% which would be quite
worrisome it would put us at the very
bottom of like all countries Hank you're
a good brother and you have good hair
it's just not this good I'll see you on
Friday